let's begin by setting the stage it is a
bloody stage indeed
it is a stage that has seen the
slaughter of 60 million human children
since roe v wade
60 million
why do some of us find this slaughter to
be
unthinkable
and an injustice
well because every single one of those
60 million were innocent and defenseless
human beings
and it is always wrong
always wrong to directly and
intentionally kill
innocent and defenseless human beings
it's as simple as that you know our
position is very straightforward that's
our whole position i just summed it
up are you killing an innocent
defenseless human being then it's wrong
that's it
the pro-abortion person here will
respond uh with with a few different
moves
the first is to try to dehumanize the
unborn of course he'll claim that the
unborn child is not a human person and
thus does not have the same moral
standing
and cannot make the same moral claims
for itself that a quote real person can
make
now the idea that an unborn child isn't
human which is something that you do
hear from pro aborts even supposedly
educated ones
is such a silly absurd anti-scientific
notion that i'm not going to spend a lot
of time on it is simply a scientific
fact
that the being in the womb is indeed a
being a living being
and it is a member of the human species
now we know that because all living
things have to be a member of some
species or another if an unborn child
isn't human then what species is it
now oftentimes what you'll hear is well
it's not a human it's a fetus
well that's like saying it's not a human
it's a boomer okay this is what maybe
kind of works sometimes but uh this is a
stage of human development
a stage of human development means that
it is a human
and we know that it's of the human
species because well it has human dna
and other human characteristics but also
it was conceived by two human beings
which is a pretty pretty good giveaway
there
two human beings have never in history
conceived anything other than another
human
now as for living is it living well
there are only three states of being
that a physical entity can be
and i think this holds true for the most
part except maybe at the quantum level
that would be most things are either
alive dead or inanimate
now
is the unborn baby inanimate
no inanimate objects don't grow they
don't develop
they don't move on their own
they don't consume food
you know this podium right here is
inanimate it will never be anything
other than this it will decay and fall
apart you could cut it into pieces and
build it into something else but it's
never on its own going to grow into
something else
because it's inanimate
um is the unborn child dead
well no we know it's not dead because if
it was dead then we wouldn't need the
abortion
so that leaves only living
okay so the baby is a living human
we've established that we've settled
that argument already that's good
what about person though well this is a
little bit more interesting because the
pro-abortion individual if he has any
degree of sophistication will probably
concede that a quote fetus or
undocumented infant as i like to call
them he'll concede that it's a living
human
but he'll say okay fine it's a living
human you're right about that but it's
not a person
and he'll say that it's not a person
because it's still developing and it is
entirely dependent on its mother for
survival and this he will say means that
it lacks moral standing
but this view that personhood is
acquired by degree and that it's forfeit
if you are entirely dependent on someone
else for survival clearly implicates
more than just the unborn it would seem
that the sick the infirm the disabled
the elderly would all get caught up in
this net
if we're not willing to do that if we're
not willing to look at an infant child
at let's say
three months out of the womb or an
elderly person in a nursing home or a
disabled person in a wheelchair if we're
not willing to look at them and say that
well you're kind of not as much of a
person as me you're a little bit less
people than me
if we're not willing to do that
if we're not willing to say that
personhood is attained by degree
contingent upon factors like
self-sufficiency
then we are left with this idea that
personhood is inherent
and all of its attending moral rights
and dignities are inherent
inherent means existing in something as
a permanent essential and characteristic
attribute of that thing
if something is inherent that means that
it belongs to the essential nature of
that thing
the idea that our human dignity our
human rights are inherent our personhood
is inherent this is an idea that lies
very much at the at the foundation of
our of our uh of our country in fact any
notion of human rights depends on this
idea
but and this is just a logical
conclusion if an unborn baby does not
have inherent value
then human value itself is not permanent
or essential and thus if an unborn baby
does not have inherent value then
neither does anybody in this room
that's the thing about inherent value
you cannot gain it
that's why it's inherent
you either have it or you don't
it's a very simple formula this is how i
try to explain to people who are
confused
take yourself in your current form
now think about yourself okay right now
you have inherent value inherent worth
you're a person great
now rewind back to yesterday
were you a person back then
did you have inherent value back then
yes okay now rewind back
10 years ago
still a person still have inherent value
now go back to your first birthday
were you a person back then
you had inherent value you had human
rights all that good stuff
now go back
to the moment
that you emerged from your mother's
birth canal
was that you
did you have inherent value
okay now rewind the clock the clock back
just 10 more seconds
just 10 more seconds
what happened in those 10 seconds
all that happened is you changed
locations that's it
it's still you my point here is that
there is an unbroken chain of youness
connecting the you of right now to the
you that came into being at the moment
of conception
and so whatever i can say is inherent in
you now i must logically say was
inherent in you then
that is why an unborn child is a human
person and that is why killing the human
person who is innocent and defenseless
is by definition murder
but really the personhood argument for
abortion is actually even worse than you
think it's so bad
the pro-abortion argument is so bad and
def and indefensible
and stupid
that i could even grant you this point
and you would still lose
let me explain why
the pro-abortion person with this
argument about personhood is really
making two assertions not one what
they're saying is number one an unborn
baby is not a person he is merely a
potential person
number two
therefore we can kill it
now wait a second
two does not flow logically from one i'm
not going to give you that
that's a whole other argument you need
to make you haven't made that argument
even if i agreed with you even if i said
okay it's not a person fine it's just a
potential person
now you need to explain to me why that
means it's okay
to suck its brains out
because i'm sure everyone in this room
right now would agree that just because
something isn't a person doesn't mean
you can kill it
i mean in this country you can't even
destroy endangered sea turtle eggs
without going to without you know facing
a fine or potentially jail time
so i don't see how you make that case
because
even if it is a potential person why
wouldn't you treat this potential person
like it is the most valuable thing in
the world
it's a potential person
how amazing is that